[موسيقى]
العراقيون
اليوم أفضل حالًا مما كانوا عليه في عهد
صدام حسين ، لقد قتلنا الكثير
من الناس بطريقة
كارثية لم يكن علينا أبدًا السماح
بتأسيس الخلافة ، هل أنا
نادم على ذلك ، نعم أفعل يا سيدي [
موسيقى]
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق  ]
[تصفيق]
أنني سأدعم الدستور وأدافع عنه
في الولايات المتحدة
ضد كل الأعداء الأجانب والمحليين
كلهم ​​في الخارج عندما أصبحت مديرًا لوكالة المخابرات المركزية ،
أحضرني الرئيس إلى
المكتب البيضاوي وقال إن
أحد  كانت
أهم الأولويات
هي ملاحقة بن لادن
ونتيجة لذلك قمت بتشكيل فريق عمل
في وكالة المخابرات المركزية
للقيام بأي شيء آخر سوى ملاحقة بن
لادن ، قلت إن هذه هي مهمتك الرئيسية
وعليك أن تقدم تقريري كل أسبوع
عن ذلك.  ما يحدث
[موسيقى]
كنا نراقب المجمع وكان هناك
شخص في منتصف العمر على الأرجح كان
يخرج كسجين في
ساحة السجن وكان يسير في دوائر
بسرعة كبيرة ثم يعود إلى
الداخل وأنا  تذكر إخبار وكالة المخابرات المركزية ، أنه
يجب عليك الحصول على
تعريف للوجه ، يمكن أن يكون بن لادن ،
وقالوا إنك تعلم
السيد المدير ،
هناك جدران يبلغ ارتفاعها 18 قدمًا ، وجدران يبلغ ارتفاعها
12 قدمًا ، ولا يمكننا حقًا الحصول على
لقطة جيدة  قلت لهم جميعًا ،
قلت إنك تعلم أنني شاهدت أفلامًا حيث
يمكن لوكالة المخابرات المركزية أن تفعل هذا بطائرة
هليكوبتر
تابعة لوكالة المخابرات المركزية الأمريكية
[موسيقى]
الليلة يمكنني إبلاغ
الشعب الأمريكي والعالم
بأن الولايات المتحدة قد أجرت
عملية  قتل أسامة بن لادن
زعيم القاعدة
[موسيقى]
أعتقد أننا استرخينا كثيرًا
أه وقد
سارت الأمور بشكل سيء ما كان يجب أن
نسمح بتأسيس
الخلافة
في الجزء الشمالي من أه
العراق وجعلتها  لا معنى له وانظر إلى
ما فعلته مع سوريا وأعني أننا ما
زلنا نقاتل أعني أن لدينا قوات
هناك لا يزال الناس يموتون بعض
الدول
شجعت
عشرات الآلاف من المقاتلين الأجانب
على القدوم إلى سوريا من أجل
إحضار
النظام السوري  لقد
استخدموا الحدود
بين العراق وسوريا ، وهذا هو أحد
الأسباب الرئيسية
لنجاح
الإرهابي في العراق ،
وكنا نتمنى ألا يكون هؤلاء الأشخاص السيئون
سيئين للغاية ، وإذا كنا لطفاء
لكانوا لطفاء فقط لذلك نحن '  سأخبز لك
كعكة في عيد ميلادك وتعال
وسنحصل جميعًا على قطعة كعكة
بشرية
أجنبية
ما فعلناه هو أننا
نشأنا
أه أه السيد الزكاري
وداعش
وهذا سمح للقتل الفوضى
أه والرعب في الوجود  في جميع أنحاء
البلاد وسمح لداعش بأن يرعى
رأسه لعقد آخر
وأن يؤسس خلافة
الآن لحسن الحظ الآن من قبل الولايات المتحدة
والمقاتلين الدوليين والعراقيين ، لقد قضوا على
الخلافة
لكنهم لم يقضوا على تنظيم الدولة لا يزال هذا
عاملاً
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى] أجنبية
لم تكن فاشلة ، حيث بلغ نصيب
الفرد من الناتج المحلي الإجمالي
في العراق اليوم خمسة أضعاف ما
كان عليه في عام 2003. وقد
انخفض معدل وفيات الأطفال ،
وأصبح متوسط ​​العمر المتوقع أطول ،
لذا
أصبح العراقيون اليوم أفضل حالًا مما كانوا عليه
في عهد صدام حسين.
حسنًا ، ليس لدى الإسلاميين السنة
برنامج أسلحة نووية
ولا لديهم
برنامج أسلحة بيولوجية كيميائية كما تفعل إيران ، فالحقيقة هي
أن القدرة على إلحاق
أضرار جسيمة تتجاوز رعب 911 ولكن
أكبر بكثير من ذلك يذهب إلى
البلاد التي  يطور كلاً من
القدرة الإرهابية وسلاح
الدمار الشامل ولهذا السبب إيران
هي التهديد المركزي
المفارقات
[موسيقى]
أه [
موسيقى]
أجنبية [موسيقى] [موسيقى
]
[موسيقى]
لا يزال يتعين علينا لعب دور
في التأكد
من عدم عودة العراق أو أفغانستان
مرة أخرى إلى قاعدة عمليات
للإرهاب
للأسف عندما غادرنا العراق وتولى
الشيعة السيطرة
أه
أزالوا السنة من
العمليات في الحكومة من
الجيش
أه والسنة سرعان ما انضموا إلى تنظيم الدولة
وأنشأوا  على القوة التي عادت
إلى العراق
والولايات المتحدة أن تعود
للتأكد من أن داعش لن تسيطر على
العراق ،
وعلينا التأكد من أننا لا نرتكب
نفس الخطأ
في أفغانستان
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
أجنبية
[موسيقى  ]
هل يؤسفني ذلك ، نعم يا سيدي
الآن ،
أنا آسف لذلك لأنه
أو أكثر من آلاف من مواطنيي ماتوا ،
لا أستطيع أن أتخيل عدد العراقيين آه
الوضع أفضل إلى حد ما الآن ولكن داعش
لا يزال موجودًا ،
أنا مرعوب من أولئك المرتبطين بالعراق
وأشعر أنه ديون أنا مدين لمواطنيي ،
ولا أشعر بأي ندم ، ولكن ندمي الوحيد هو
أننا لم نفعل ذلك في عام 1991. أتمنى
ألا يكون لدي أي علاقة به في
كل حالة وفاة حدثت في العراق في
الجانب العراقي ومن الجانب الأمريكي ، والجانب
البريطاني ،
وأطراف التحالف الأخرى ،
أشعر أنني أتحمل بعض المسؤولية
عن
عدم الشعور بالرضا
ولا أعتقد أن هناك
اهتمامًا لفهم 9 11 جيدًا
بعد الآن ، وأعتقد أنه من العام الماضي
أجيال اليوم القادمة
لا أعتقد أن دروسهم التي تعلمناها
قد تم أخذها على محمل الجد ولإثبات
وجهة نظري أننا ما زلنا لا نبلي بلاءً
حسنًا في الحرب على الإسلام الراديكالي ، لا
يزال بإمكاني أن أريكم بوكو حرام ، ولا يزال بإمكاني أن
أريكم الفظائع  لا يزال بإمكاني الذهاب
إلى أي بلد تريده وأظهر لك
أن الأمور أقل استقرارًا الآن
مما كانت عليه عندما غادرت الوكالة في عام
2006. وأنا لا أمزح ، فنحن نعرف كيف
نلاحق الإرهابيين ونقتلهم
ولكن شيئًا واحدًا  لم نعمل على كيفية
منع
الإرهابيين
من أن يصبحوا إرهابيين ، وهذا
شيء لم
نركز عليه بقدر ما نركز عليه ،
ولا نتعلم دروسًا في أمريكا ، لقد
تسببنا في فوضى قتلنا الكثير من الناس مليوني
ونصف المليون شخص.  لقد ألقينا
المزيد من القنابل الحديدية على شمال فيتنام ولاوس
وكامبوديا أكثر مما أسقطناه في
الحرب العالمية الثانية
ولم نتعلم شيئًا ،
لذا فإن الإجابة على سؤالك هي أن
الأمريكيين لا يتعلمون أي شيء
أميركي يجب أن نطلق عليهم اسم الولايات المتحدة
لفقدان الذاكرة
[  موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لك